yes carissa you have the number two seed
in the tournament been on sort of a
roller coaster coaster ride carissa you
beat arena and an easy game and then you
lost
you you got to say it was a bad game
yesterday
against begin and this game today we
don't know how you survived coming out
of that opening what were your thoughts
after
the first eight moves
and your position just looked not so
pleasant
yeah i mean after
bishop c4 i felt at first i was like i
feel like c takes d4
it's pretty good for me because i could
tell that like bishop takes f7 wasn't
really working out for her
um and then i saw knight g5 and i spent
like a really long time calculating that
and kind of decided like
i mean i was looking at all sorts of
stuff with like e6 or queen a5 but i
felt like everything was kind of too
crazy
and so
um
and so i couldn't really like think of a
move after
bishop c4 and i saw i burned like half
an hour already and i was like okay
queen a5 looks
good enough i guess
not just praying for the best but then
she played bishop d2 and that's a
monster move yeah and your position is
in serious crisis just about right away
after this this move
uh
you did play h6 which we were cringing
at when we saw this one too you're
thinking what's going to happen the e5
looks strong and this is like a big
attack but then she backed down and
didn't play the most aggressive
continuation gave you a chance to get
back in the game yeah i guess you just
um
want to get like more of a
solid-ish position where she's like
slightly better
and
i think like what happened in the game
was that she missed that i have e5 and
if i don't play e5 then my position's
like
kind of iffy
um
but since i do have e5 i feel like i
should be good here because after she
oh she's like forced to exchange knights
and then uh
afterwards
i always have like this d5 push that's
really hard for her to stop
yeah that's exactly right all your
analysis is true there and we're gonna
ask you when the moment did come you
have d5 right now and you played b6
instead why didn't you go for d5 yeah i
mean i was calculating d52 and okay
bishop takes is the only move i suppose
and yeah rook takes takes
e4
i mean i don't know this is
this is probably really good for black
but i thought i want to play like a
little bit more safe because
that tough loss yesterday so she's
trying not to lose again that's what we
were thinking i think christian said
that you were thinking about the ghost
of yesterday by the way yesterday you
played this movie knight c8 instead of
knight c4 and we just wanted to cry at
least i wanted to cry
i saw the replay maurice i'm sorry to
disappoint you
why were you watching the replay
because everyone was like maurice was
roasting you so hard and i was like
well we're going to talk about that
tomorrow
look charissa you can't play moves like
knight c8 come on yeah i mean i mean um
i just missed that after knight c4
there's like queen b3 bishop f1 ideas
um and i felt like i had to defend the
night by playing like rick c8 in which
case there are like some weird tactics
of
uh
like rixie one and then
uh i can't really get into the lines
right now because i don't quite remember
but like i missed i have like this rick
d4 defense instead of ruxia which is
like so much better and then my position
stays together
but
yeah don't don't i was saying don't put
a knight on c8 even if you put a gun to
my head i'm not backing my piece up and
go through that kind of position but so
you did play a little bit safe today as
well
with the move b6 instead of playing for
d5 but slowly she lets you all the way
back and then suddenly it was you with
the initiative
yeah i mean um
i feel like it was just kind of a little
hard for her to play after i close up
the queen side and started pushing my
pawns on the
on the king's side and i feel like
her g3 f4 idea was definitely um
not the best it would have been harder
for me to break through but yeah i mean
i saw that position coming and i was
like okay i feel like i could probably
i'll play her here just because there's
like some pressure on her
so emotionally you've gone through an
easy game that was happy days ahead a
bad game that was dejection
a difficult opening and then a win it's
like right now to me if i'm your coach
i'm on a roller coaster ride watching
you play where's your emotional state
right now after this game you're
despite all that tied for first yeah i
mean after
after yesterday i was really not feeling
my best
um
but i mean
i had some friends who helped me like
put into perspective they're like you're
still half a point behind first so
you just gotta like get out of your own
head a little bit and uh
stop stressing so much because like for
me i feel like
um
i always come into this tournament i'm
always like really nervous about and so
i don't i don't play to my strength
usually and i'm just hoping to change
that with the remaining half of the
tournament oh you did so so far
tough road
uh to this point but you're tied for
first good luck in the rest of your
games and you're right don't stress so
much and i'm not roasting you but if you
make a bad move i got to talk about it
oh i i i get that i respect it yes
deserve to be roasted for it for that
one
carissa you you were talking with
maurice and you gave a lot of variations
and i'm sure a lot of our viewers wanted
to see what you were saying so if you
don't mind i just brought your game up
that you played yesterday which maurice
took you to task for for not playing the
move knight c4 and there's a lot of
other people behind maurice by the way
yes but you were saying you rejected
knight c4 because you saw
the move queen b3 and then you saw ideas
of bishop f1 and that threw you off okay
so here in this line um
you have to protect your knife takes
d8 and that takes e6 first whichever
okay um knight takes e6 right
queen takes e6
okay and then here i was thinking like
bishop f1 i missed i had rook d4 and i
thought i had to play
rook c8
yeah so ricky for here and i'm fine i
thought i had to play like rick c8 okay
and then i saw this line of like bishop
g5 okay
h6 right
roxy one i got you and then after i take
the bishop bishop takes c4 bishop takes
f7 and you're crying yeah yeah gotcha
that was what you saw and scared you
away from this whole line you just
simply missed rook d4 then yeah i mean i
just missed rick difor and i'm just
holding everything together
she can't get rid of my rick there
and your night
in the game you got all of these passive
pieces i don't want to bore you with
that but yeah i think she remembers what
happened yeah yeah yeah yeah it was good
it was good all right well well done
today to close that out and good luck
tomorrow thank you absolutely good luck
carissa